good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy hump day it looks like a hump day
it
feels seems like a hump day but it
doesn't feel like a hump day because
theo is not here today and that is on me
i apologize i have things to do after
the show
and was unfortunately not able to bring
my son to work today
but that is you know the life of a mom
like things are up and down all the time
totally totally maybe you guys can
celebrate hump day later yeah you know
what's funny is
i can always tell when we get like a
resurgence of or just like a wave of new
toasters because
i get so many comments like literally
for the past two weeks thought theo was
your son
right your human son right which is why
it's important to have him here to show
everyone but this is theo he's not a
human but he's also not a dog
par part of my rationale behind not
bringing theo today was
really inspired by a conversation we had
on yesterday's controversy from
yesterday due to the hypocrisy that i
was exuding
on unbeknownst to me um where you know i
was talking about how i really don't
like watching shows that use real
animals because it's like
what is an animal doing on a set and as
those words came out of my mouth
my animal was in fact on a set no yes
you're what
technical technical animal so i don't
know
maybe there's going to be some changes
no no i'm totally kidding i would have
never said that if i knew no
i realized where this was headed i
realized the hypocrisy in my statements
yesterday but
theo this is not a set like yeah and you
know what i'll give you i'll give you
your um rebuttal
okay if you will do you have a problem
with animals on reality tv shows
exactly or no no like if let's say you
know um
jessica alba is starring in a movie and
she brings her dog to set like and hangs
out in the trailer
i think that's okay yeah no but the the
i understand what you're saying so if
anyone like tries to come for you just
say i don't have a problem with animals
on reality tv shows they're in their
element and we're just watching them in
there
but i'll have to figure out you know
what to do
for hump day when theo's not here so i
just think you should watch your back
after the show
very fair thanks for the warning you got
it so it's wednesday it's hump day that
means we have a fabulous show as always
but we also have
our favorite segment dear toasters which
is our advice segment
again if you ever want to write in we
always keep things anonymous and the
email is dear toasters gmail.com we've
got three for you today
and i know i say this virtually every
wednesday but
i love wednesdays like deer toasters has
become like
i used to just like do it because it was
wednesday but now like i like i see the
cards when i walk in and they're right
here and i'm
so excited you live six days for one
that's what i'm well
i live five days for four no for one you
do four shows for one
i do five shows for one yeah no but it's
like i live ten months for two you don't
include the two
oh yeah so you do four shows for one
yeah thank you thank you yeah always
taking it back to ten months for two
always that is like the cornerstone of
like and the mantra in which our found
like our whole life
was built on there's two types of people
in this world people who live 10 months
for two
and people i don't want to know oh no no
there's two types of people in this
world
people who live 10 months for two and
liars no but like some people never went
to camp they might not even know what
we're talking about do you want to hear
the funniest thing over the weekend i
was with like four people
um margot
the snatchers so margo and her roommate
nicole who hosts this natural podcast
ben and ben's friend elliot and we were
like talking about camp and i was like
like did you ever go to camp and he was
like yeah of course i loved camp and i
was like going on and on about how like
people who just didn't go to camp are
like
so weird and unbeknownst to me nicole
didn't go to camp and literally she made
the weirdest face i'm like what she's
like i didn't go to camp i'm like
what and then i found out she did go to
soccer camp so that totally counts but
it was like
it was like a three week thing but it
counts yeah that's like a while ago i
was hanging out with dana and we were
trying to teach her a tick-tock dance
and the first step is kickball change so
i was like kickball changed and she was
like what
and i was like i don't associate with
people who don't know how to kickball
change she also went to camp and she
should know what a kickball change
every camper who took a rudimentary
dance class
knows what a kickball chain is and if
you were really into the dancing camp
you would also know what a potaboo ray
is but that is not basic standard
a kickball change is so it's tech and
grain
yeah a chasse too like across the floor
with your arms out
um and you know you would have to like
line up in the corner and then like go
diagonal chasse and twos across the
dance floor fabulous
fabulous i mean i used to like dread
like after school activities that we did
like piano lessons or dance lessons
tennis lessons like
i literally they were the bane of my
existence i hated them so much and i
would just love now to like have a
tennis
lesson once a week a piano lesson once a
week chefs say across a dance floor once
a week
like we didn't even know how good it was
we didn't know
but to appreciate it kid life childhood
is really made like
would be better suited for adults yes i
can say that about a lot of things
similar to camp which is why we started
camp toast
yeah which we're not having this year
which is which is a loss it's a loss
i've actually dreamed about it a few
times
good dreams man good dreams good dreams
um
speaking of other good dreams not really
at all yesterday we filmed
i think the funniest patreon episode
we've ever done and i know that like a
lot of
a lot of episodes have gotten that title
i'll tell you some of the top ones that
are competing for the title
drunk get ready get ready with me the
spending a thousand dollar gift card at
became like a crowd favorite um people
have the zoom happy hour all steam time
that was a good one
but i just want to say i when editing
this video yesterday
i have never laughed so hard in the
editing process i probably watched a
video four times backwards and forwards
and i was on the floor you you were so
funny you know i'm glad you had a good
time recording it because it was really
like an emotional journey for me it was
somewhat traumatizing
i haven't actually seen i think my
entire say yes to the dress episode in
in full and if i have it hasn't been for
four years
so we sat down and we watched it and we
did like reactions to it and we told
like you know more behind the scenes
stuff things they cut out things you
didn't see
and it was i knew it was bad like you
know i remember being like
not loving the episode but i don't think
i really
remembered how like awful i came off and
now all the tweets i mean they literally
re-enter my episode multiple times a
month like it's crazy
and i don't know if they just do it
because my episode is particularly
terrible or they just
like re-air everyone's yeah um but there
are
15 seasons like and i feel like mine
definitely gets played more
and i understand people who like don't
know me and who tweet like man they just
tweet at me like this girl on the job
check is annoying like say like one more
time they're totally right
okay well i've been reading the comments
on the episode and one
people absolutely love it rolling just
like us their favorite episode and two
so many people commented
that they actually discovered you and
this show
from say yes to the dress they're so
grateful that
say yes to the dress brought you into
their lives and so
it's all good you know i have no regrets
about like signing on to
the show no part of me which is that i
didn't do it but there are definitely
things i regret saying yeah and you can
find out which things she regrets saying
at patreon.com
slash the morning toast um it's it's
fabulous yeah we literally sat in front
of my giant tv and just
cringed for 40 minutes straight it is a
hilarious vlog
and also if you join patreon now to
become
um a member because you want to watch
this video you also get access to all
the old episodes so some of the
videos we mentioned like um drunk get
ready with me and whatever else you are
now able to access those we have like
over 200 episodes
podcast videos vlogs all the stuff so
all the stuff so head over to
patreon.com
the morning toast that was fun and
literally i was sweating like an animal
because when we vlog
and when we podcast we turn the air
conditioning off i also happen to have
commercial air conditioning units in my
apartment don't ask
and they're so loud so we had to turn it
off and i was just like anxious watching
it and it was [ __ ] hot yeah we were
both wearing like sweaters
and i was like broken dead like i had to
fully take a nap afterwards because it
was
it was emotionally draining it was it
was but she laid it all out for you guys
so definitely consume definitely consume
um also maybe some of you are noticing
um i'm just like looking amazing it's
because i got a spray tan for the first
time since
february and man did it feel good like
you know usually you get naked in front
of anna who doesn't spray chance it's
like a little you know like i'm naked
you know
i was like i couldn't get my robe off
fast enough i'm like spray
me and it just felt amazing and i missed
you know all the things i used to not
like about spray tans like oh i can't
you know my sheets are stained like i
don't even care i'm like living for the
normalcy of it all mm-hmm
and the smell i actually i'm never
bothered by the smell
ben can't stand it i know even when i
use just um
self tanner on my legs like that can't
stand it it has like the same key
ingredient all spray tanners or self
tanners i don't know what it is ben says
it smells like wet dog
and he like refuses to talk talk to me
or touch me yeah it's not the best smell
in the world but it's certainly not the
worst
but you know what it smells like beauty
and that's truly like all i care about
i agree um so we got some stories we got
some things going on i did watch
the second half of the shots of sunset
reunion and i have some thoughts um
i feel like i'll get into it okay and
i started season three of yellowstone
because it's like on air now
okay so um i'm up to season three
episode three which has just been
such a treat and then once i'm all
caught up we could discuss
what channels does it air on i it's
unparamount i didn't know that channels
was still in existence
me neither one and i watch it now on the
paramount app when you hear
people watch seasons one and two on
peacock when you hear paramount network
on the count of three say what it makes
you think of
one two three kyle richards yes i didn't
know if you were gonna say american
woman or kyle richards and i was trying
to think of the name of the show but
do you think i remember the name of the
show like not seriously no
okay well i think without further ado
let's just get right into the fast five
stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
sure and as mentioned today's episode is
brought to you by our patreon channel
that's patreon.com morning toast a
fabulous way for you to spend eight
dollars a month
get tons of content be a part of a
community you get to be a part of our
facebook group
and then you also get to support the
show which we love and we do every day
for free so
figure it out head over to patreon.com
love it
sign on get premium content to fill your
days with joy and steaminess
endless steeniness this steeniness is
endless
and it is contagious watch out it's
that movie contagion was about the
steaminess
okay first story nominations for the
72nd
primetime emmy awards were announced on
tuesday and it was a diverse
mix with old favorites like game of
thrones and veep out of contention
shows like the mandalorian insecure and
shit's creek received
multiple nods wow that's fascinating
yeah um we'll get to this in a little
bit but
moira rose deserves an emmy for once and
for [ __ ] all was she nominated
i believe she was nominated oh my god
she deserves to win the category
it's the last season of jesus creek and
she
is so worthy of course but to be honest
i don't feel like game of thrones and
veep should have had to end for her to
at least get nominated no she had been
nominated
she didn't win netflix dominated with
160 nominations which is a new record
as new services like disney plus apple
tv also made
their mark so here are the nominees and
claudia and i are going to cast our
votes okay
outstanding lead actor in a limited
series or tv movie
some of these categories are so specific
oh my god what's a limited series does
that mean series
would be what big little lies was before
they chose to do another season so a one
season
moment okay noble which you should watch
okay jeremy irons watchmen
hugh jackman bad education that was a tv
movie i've heard that's actually
really good i haven't seen it paul
mezcal normal people
oh winner winner hottie paul mezcal like
still dreaming about him he's got my
vote i don't care who else
jeremy pope hollywood but who plays
who's jeremy pope
i'm googling it now who he plays
hollywood was actually very good and a
lot of the actors were pretty fabulous
so
oh he plays the writer um of the movie
let me see oh he was great he was great
i wonder if hollywood got a lot of
nominations because the acting was very
good okay
and mark ruffalo i know this much is
true never heard of it
so the politician is not a limited
series no because there's there were two
seasons so that'll be a different
category
perhaps okay so for this i'm totally
casting my vote for normal people
paul mezcal was so good and i loved him
so much like he made me want to just go
to dublin and fall in love with an
irishman he was very good i would give
him my vote too i just i couldn't finish
normal people
it it literally took me to such a dark
and depressed place why
and it was actually unhealthy
but the sex it was it was too good to
pass no it was
it was too dark and i had read the book
so i didn't need like i knew
what happened they stuck to the script
really closely so
i just couldn't finish it i i it was too
heavy that's crazy because like i
finished it in like less than a day and
when it was over i was like devastated
wow and that's crazy that you liked it i
know i had my problems with the ending
of course but
whatever outstanding lead actress in a
limited series or tv movie
kate blanchett miss america shira haas
unorthodox she was great
oh she was fabulous regina king watchman
octavia spencer self-made
also fabulous carrie washington little
fires everywhere
um i think i'm gonna go with octavia
spencer great story
loved everything about it and octavia
really brought life to the role i
completely agree
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series anthony anderson blackish
don cheadle black monday ted danson the
good place
michael douglas the kaminsky method
eugene levy shit's creek
rami yusef rami i gotta go with
you mr eugene levy and shit's creek it's
the show as a whole even though johnny
rose i don't have a horse in this race
yeah of those shows i think that maybe
shit's creek is the only one that i
watch
but i don't think that makes eugene levy
the winner here i haven't seen the other
shows but i'm sure
they're better he's not to me he's not
the best part
or even like the top five best things
about shit's greek he's honestly really
[ __ ] annoying
so i i don't have a vote here yeah me
neither outstanding lead actress in a
comedy series
christina applegate dead to me oh she
was very good
rachel brosnahan the marvelous mrs
maisel also excellent
linda cardellini dead to me very good
katherine o'hara shit's creek oh this is
a tough
category disarray insecure oh and tracy
ellis ross blackish
oh my god honestly any one of these
women could win agreed this
by the way that's that's really tough
yeah but for me i think moira rose
considering it's the last season but
that's not a reason to win but she's
been worthy every season
i of course i agree but it's a like
it's not an easy win like this is not by
any means going to be a landslide like
that's
really every single person in that
category like dominates their show
that's really hard
yeah okay outstanding lead actor in a
drama series
jason bateman ozark sterling k brown
this is us
steve carell the morning show brian cox
succession
billy porter pose jeremy strong
succession
i don't watch any of those shows so i'm
just going to go with billy porter
because
i would like to see him giving a speech
as opposed to any of those other people
that's a great reason too i think so too
and like the look he'll provide for us
it's just it's multi-dimensional the
reasons why i think he should win yeah
beyond his performance which i'm sure
was great i never saw it
yeah i agree with you there outstanding
lead actress in a drama series
jennifer aniston the morning show olivia
coleman the crown
winner winner chicken dinner
jude uh jody comer killing eve laura
linney
ozark sandra oh killing eve zendaya
euphoria oh
you know i of those shows i only watched
the crown
and i actually think olivia coleman did
an amazing job as queen
um after claire foy which i feel like is
not an easy like people
yeah aren't gonna like you they've
gotten used to claire foy like it was a
disruption
amongst and honestly i remember being
like who the hell is this
but i think she was fabulous and i
really really like her but
i think zendaya could get it my vote is
for olivia coleman
yeah i don't know i haven't watched um
i haven't watched enough of the shows to
say that i think olivia coleman was
really good and i agree with what you're
saying but i might feel that way about
killing eve
right if i took the time to watch it
yeah which i've heard it's really good
yes
outstanding reality competition series
oh my god reality shows can win emmys
competition yes the mask singer
nailed it rupaul's drag race oh
top chef and the voice rupaul's drag
race may the best woman best woman win
i mean rupaul's drag race literally
created
i can't even go into what rupaul's drag
race has done because it's such a
phenomenal show
and they just keep elevating themselves
you know the rest of the reality
competition she doesn't need to meet
rupaul up here because
they're still here no doubt in my mind
there's literally no
no question no question
outstanding variety talk series daily
show with trevor noah full frontal with
samantha bee
jimmy kimmel live last week tonight with
john oliver a late show with stephen
colbert
i literally hate every single one of
these shows like truly could care less
no like i literally hate every single
one of these shows like and i've never
seen a minute of any of them i just know
that like they're not funny
yeah no i'm i hope they're not they're
not outstanding
no no and what do i have like watch what
happens live i completely agree
i completely morning toast like you know
yeah
i don't think you have to be on a
network i don't think we would be in
this category anyway
nightly pop like you know what i mean to
me these are such antiquated shows like
jimmy kimmel really again like come on
come on outstanding limited series
little fires everywhere
mrs america unbelievable unorthodox
watchmen i have to say unbelievable was
unbelievable like it was i watched the
whole thing on a really long plane ride
it was incredible and i didn't even know
what it was about and like the way all
the stories ended up connecting
but unorthodox was also sensational i'm
going with unorthodox because i think
that
the and i haven't seen everything here
but the way that it was done and the
um i mean the recreation of you know the
that community but also the yiddish
speaker that's what i was gonna say
um every facet of it was just
unbelievably well done
they literally wrote a show that was
that's in
like a dying language no it's it's a
forgotten language it's dead i don't
think it's dying like it's pretty much
dead
i just i'm being hopeful no i know like
me too um
it was incredible yeah i think
unorthodox as well
also i just want to say little fires
everywhere like is getting some
nominations here i guess people were
upset that reese was snubbed for the
nomination i really thought the show was
absolutely nothing of the sort
and and to add to that i don't think
reese was much of the sort like i
honestly
agree with her not getting nominated
yeah and i just
i think it's like it's gotten nominated
because it was made
right you know but that's not enough of
a reason no i literally was like
so on board and excited and i didn't
even finish it like that's how not good
it was
yeah outstanding comedy series fun
category curb your enthusiasm
winner dead to me also good the good
place
insecure the kaminsky method i feel like
that show wins every year
yeah the marvelous mrs maisel also wins
every year shits creek and what we do in
the shadows
well this is the first year that i
actually have watched the marvelous mrs
maisel as opposed to just like talking
[ __ ] about it with never having seen a
moment of it so do you agree
with all of the accolades it has
received 1 000
it is a [ __ ] sensational show like
really really truly remarkable like the
way they've
really recreated new york in the i think
it's the 50s or something
it's unreal some of the jewish tropes
are like a little overt for me and
border on a little like offensive but
it's
really really sensational um but the
winner here is so clearly curb your
enthusiasm like how anyone thinks
any of those shows are funnier than curb
your enthusiasm like doesn't know comedy
yeah i just am also pulling again i'm
just
a broken record shit's creek does it it
deserves to win an emmy
is it in that category it's in that
category and it was the last season and
i don't know if they what emmys they've
won in the past but like
they deserve to go out on this high you
know what it is it's also i can't even
speak because i haven't watched the last
season yet and this is like awards for
the last season
because i'm saving it for like a day
when i need it you know
and i just i love to have things to look
forward to me too like do you think they
get rich again in the end
and then like decide to stay in
shitscreen oh i wonder i have no idea
that's what i haven't thought about how
it might end and then they like build a
mansion on a hill in shitscreen oh
that's really cute and like give back to
the community oh my god i would love
that me too
okay wow i never thought johnny's
accountant uncovers like a offshore
account
yeah i never thought about how it might
end yeah
okay an outstanding drama series better
call saul
the crown handmaid's tale killing eve
the mandalorian
ozark stranger things succession
i mean i only watched the crown and what
was one right after it handmaid's tale
and
absolutely not absolutely not you should
not be awarded
for terrorizing people and taunting
their dreams absolutely not i think it
sends a bad message
so i'm gonna see the crown because
that's the only one i watch yeah i think
the crown is outstanding i've tried to
walk
watch succession now three times and i
could not get past the second episode
so but i know people love it and then
it's so good and i think they had like a
really great season so i feel like they
might be
sweeping but i also think that the
mandalorian though i've never watched it
and never cared to
it brought baby yoda into our lives and
that has become such a cultural staple
i think the emmys need to consider that
when making their decision of course
cultural implications
should hold value yeah they should and i
hope that the academy
addresses that baby oda is the ultimate
camper big time
big time camper so those are the major
categories those are the nominations
those are our thoughts and
what i'm realizing is i do not have any
horses in this race i do not watch
award-winning television yeah you know
what though what's so interesting is i
really feel like the emmys
for a while were like the lowest of the
ego
on the totem pole it's just like emmys
and there really wasn't that much
competition there were a couple like
really really good tv shows but it
wasn't like every category was stacked
and i just feel like so many like major
stars have really invested so much in tv
that's due to streaming services yeah
because of the major contracts that
they're getting the money sources that
they're putting behind it it's not just
now you have to have a show on
it used to be like the silver screen
versus the small screen
but now it's just all one screen and now
when you have like limited series
is that's kind of like an in between a
movie and a television show the lines
are really getting blurred and i agree
that
premium premium content is coming out
via television
with like megastar megastars and it's
due to what the streaming services can
offer them in terms of distribution
and a big payday paycheck so i just
think it's honestly i used to like skip
the emmys but it's becoming
real staple in my ear i think that the
golden globes are the lowest on the
totem pole because they're just like the
junior oscars
and they're both tv and it's like if
you're on tv you really want to win the
emmy like you know
yeah i guess it it's the one that
bridges both tv and movies but
i think um a little music as well i love
a little music me too
okay next story some really exciting
news that put a smile on my face because
we
take the positive news that we can get
in terms of moving forward okay
real housewives of new york is set to
film an in-person reunion
next week i saw this
like this is so exciting obviously for
the content but just for
what it means for where we stand in
terms of moving forward in this pandemic
is fabulosity yes and of course i want
to be positive but like of course it has
to happen with like literally the worst
cast of new york like why not beverly
hills like the season
they just filmed it a week ago your [ __ ]
you're so right i know so it's like
if they had waited two weeks i don't
know but la is still behind me you have
to think every state is so different
la still is behind andy is in new york
yes
so i wonder i'm assuming that factored
into the decision i mean that's so
exciting and i'm sure they'll limit like
hair makeup i'm sure not every housewife
can have like a million stylists like
i'm sure it's like two
people per housewife yeah or maybe
everyone has to show up
ready oh that would be a good idea and
like they'll have one on set makeup
artist and hair artist to touch up
yeah yeah to go over the mask lines yeah
there are ways to do it and i feel like
honestly when i was reading andy's book
like for so long the reunions were such
a [ __ ] and so much information
was getting leaked
because there were tons of people in
everyone's dressing room there's 10
housewives five people in every dressing
room that's already 50 people
besides production so i feel like
whatever they end up doing will probably
really benefit reunions as a whole
because they they've gone on far too
long for being like kind of messy like
so much information gets leaked
before it even comes out yeah that's
true well the real housewives of new
york city will be able to fight each
other in person next week instead of
duking it out online the reality
showcase will be shooting an in-person
reunion on august 5th
on long island a source tells page six
exclusively interesting
bravo boss and watch what happens live
instigator andy cohen
will be in attendance sources tell us
covet precautions are still being ironed
out for the taping
but they will be following cdc
guidelines such as using a limited crew
and mandatory face masks
also i'm assuming the women will be six
feet apart um oh that's so interesting
well
then they're not gonna have violent wear
masks i don't think
if they're six feet apart them doing it
in long island is actually so
fascinating because
um they'll probably do it somewhere near
the hamptons ramone is in the hamptons
at least he's in the hamptons andy's in
the hamptons in the hamptons with elise
elise is not on the schedule no she is
not
and i don't believe tinsley will be
flying in from chicago
i'm cool with both of those things very
cool
very cool as a cucumber so it'll really
be a kind of small cast it'll be ramona
luanne dorinda sonia
leah yeah oh that's five yeah well they
have to be six feet apart anyway so
there's a limited amount of space
honestly
works for me works for me i'm so glad
we're moving forward with like in-person
reunions because while the zoom ones
have been way better than i expected and
with each one they're getting a little
better like
this the first one was atlanta and it
was good but then with shots of sunset
banner from rules and uh beverly hills
like they get better every time and
the cameras are better the mics are
better but nothing beats being in person
no nothing beats it so while i do wish
it was another show
all of these good exciting news yeah
okay next story some more good exciting
news
oprah winfrey reveals in a new interview
she reveals a new interview
show and is rethinking print future of
oh magazine
oprah announced on monday that her new
show the oprah conversation will debut
exclusively on apple tv for free at 6 00
p.m
on thursday also she'll be refocusing
her monthly magazine
to a digitally centric magazine i mean
oprah is a maven and you know
working in in publishing is not easy
these days
and good on oprah for having the
foresight you know while under house
arrest
to you know make the changes necessary
for her business
yeah i think a digitally centric
magazine is a great call
and i think an oprah conversation
television show is an amazing call
and i also heard that they were
launching a podcast i mean
and we would welcome over open arms she
would be a fabulous podcaster
no this boy is too fabulous for
podcasting which is why it needs to be
on tv
yeah but she's the ultimate podcaster if
you think about it you know if i ever
got to be as rich as oprah i would do
exactly what she did
start a magazine where i'm on the cover
every week every month and named after
me like
can you say genius yeah genius this is
really exciting
and uh hosting news entertainment news
consumption news
biz news and biz news because it's an
interesting step
in print publication or like thereof
or lack thereof spooky quite spooky
was that the last story no we have two
more stories oh wow yeah what were you
looking at me like that for i don't know
oh okay okay are you ready for the next
story am i supposed to say something am
i missing something oh
you're fine okay megan fox and machine
gun kelly make it instagram official
quote waited an eternity to find you
this makes me so happy
this makes me so happy i love megan
kelly i love megan kelly
they are so beautiful they are so
beautiful
and they're hanging out with la la and
they're hanging out with love yeah
that's the channel they're doing her
podcast we love people who respect
podcasts
the couple posed for black and white
mirror selfie which the rapper uh shared
on his instagram account on tuesday
quote waited for eternity to find you
again kelly wrote in the caption
um this is just so cute the picture they
posted is so cute i didn't realize we
were
waiting for them to make it instagram
official me neither because it was
already official in my mind i've been
thinking about it nonstop since i first
heard about it
it was like paparazzi official it was
podcast official it was everything
official
and um now i guess it's instagram
official yeah i mean
their love story is one i just love so
much
but i think like the most valuable thing
we've gotten out of it is that song
bloody valentine that they did the music
video for
i have not been able to stop listening
to it it is so good
yeah and now i think i'm like a machine
gun cali like stan
i mean because i'm obviously a machine
gun kelly and megan kelly fan
yeah but it has led me down a road of
machine gun kelly's music which is
actually quite fabulous
yeah and i i think we've had this
conversation already yeah i'm about to
say i think ben would like it too
he loves it we've had this conversation
yeah so that's
well we'll leave that but i'm excited
for these two i'm excited that
they're hanging out with randall and
lala really and
i just in my head wish eternal love for
them they speak
on the podcast about how when they met
each other they it was just
instantaneous they knew
that's how you know in flames oh love to
hear love to see it
something about them like gives me real
i feel like
you know how kids today like emo tumblr
kids like post pictures of like winona
ryder and johnny depp when they were
like 17 being like
mood i literally feel like kids in 10
years are gonna post pictures whether or
not they're together
of machine gun kelly and megan kelly the
kids who are really into like the emo
scene or like the rock scene
yeah and it's gonna be like mood yeah
this photo that they posted on instagram
definitely made their ads on tumblr
yesterday
100 like emo tumblr is sobbing yeah i
agree that's a very good call
you know it's like and people love to
post like early 90s pictures of like
brad pitt like
on red carpets like of celebrities who
we know but like had totally different
looks that were like kind of iconic when
they were teenagers you know who else
i'm feeling that way about since we
reported about them
who brooklyn beckham and nicole lapel
yeah i don't like the people who write
the captions for e-news like literally
can't breathe without talking about
nicola peltz and brooklyn beckham like
once a week
and honestly i totally forget about them
all the time because i don't follow
either of them on instagram and like i
don't
actually care but happy for two
beautiful people who found each other
and who probably never have to work in
their lives you know yeah
that's a beautiful story claudia
that's beautiful yeah make sure to order
my comedy special disgraced queen
now streaming on many platforms if you
head over to my instagram account girl
with no job
there's a highlight called disgrace
queen it has links to all the places you
could buy
purchase stream rent my comedy special
and my comedy album
so if you like listening to podcasts you
can listen to my entire show
as an album on spotify apple music
pandora all the places amazon music
so it's fabulous for a long car ride
it's fabulous for a long car ride
okay ready for our fifth and final story
i mean i'm sad but yeah
it's the sooner you get into your
toasters so it makes you so happy so
true
ed sheeran is opening up about his quote
addictive personality yes
he starts getting sad ed sharon is
reflecting on how his addictive
personality led to struggles with binge
eating and drinking
during an interview for the hay house
chasing the present
summit the shape of you singer reflected
on his unhealthy lifestyle
during his ex world tour in 2015. quote
for me it was down to bad diet drinking
and then not seeing sunlight at all so i
was touring
oh and i wasn't exercising i would stay
up and drink all night the buses would
park underneath arenas and i'd sleep on
the bus all day
and then wake up and then come out do
the show drink get back on the bus
i didn't see sunlight for like maybe
four months
it's all fun and games at the start it's
all rock and roll and then it starts
getting just sad
so i think that was probably the lowest
that i've been yeah i mean
i don't think like a tour that big is
so insane like the way that you're
scheduled out and i don't think most
people
can really handle that type of schedule
um
and especially if you have this type of
personality which i didn't know that ed
sheeran had it's obviously not a healthy
environment to be in
yeah but and i feel this explains why
in the past he's sort of taken long
breaks and his
from working i think probably to
recharge because it does become a cycle
and artists talk about it
it's right album tour right you know
that's what happened took down one
direction
yeah and so i think it's really
important to prioritize taking time for
yourself and also enjoying the
fruits of your labor right like what's
the point in making over a million
dollars to show if you're literally just
working the next day and you don't have
time to enjoy it
yeah and i feel like his fiance
girlfriend wife i don't know what they
are
like partner i feel like they got
married i feel like they did too
um i feel like she's a real stable force
in his life and that was like the best
thing for him
yeah okay i mean she might be his
girlfriend but to me they're just like
they're otp you know i don't question it
no i don't need to put a label on it
but my absolute favorite picture of them
is like them like partying leaving a
club
in london at like 1am and she is wearing
his sneakers and he's barefoot
holding her heels so cute that's so cute
that's love and she's just like a
regular girl and he's like a regular guy
like it's
i really like him as a couple yeah he
said also that he's reading elton john's
book at the moment and there's so many
things that he did that i do
he would be like i would just go on an
ice cream binge and eat four [ __ ]
desserts until i threw up
and i was like oh i've done that before
and so i feel like that's what we saw in
rocket man so yeah that's the story that
they tell so it's easy for us
not easy but to picture it we can
imagine what it looks like
and so i'm glad that he's taking the
time and getting the help that he needs
right away
it's clear that he's not just talking
about like drugs or alcohol it's like
addiction to everything yeah and it's
just the whole
environment yeah that sets you up
when you have unlimited resources to do
and say and get whatever you want like
how do you not get out of control
right and just like he said in the
beginning i'm sure it's all fun and
games and it's rock and roll and we're
drinking and we're partying but like
it goes it gets really sad yes and
i think the food part i think is one
that like i can totally relate to and i
just find it interesting
that like that's another layer of
success it's like again
the gluttonous vibe where like you want
to have everything
that includes food too yeah that's crazy
yeah
and that was also like in rocket man the
shopping for elton john's yes which i
could relate to
yesterday um it's that was a great word
to use gluttonous we all have our
addictions
we do not not that i do but shopping
no you do i think i'm fine no i think a
healthy sometimes i'm addicted to
investing
oh please okay dear toasters everyone
our advice segment if you ever want to
write us in dear toasters gmail.com we
appreciate you writing in
and we always keep it anonymous like
this next girl or boy i don't know
dear toasters first off thank you for
keeping me sane during the queue i have
a weird
question about my relationship for you
here is some backstory
my boyfriend and i have been together
for six years we've broken up three
times within that time
but currently we've been together for
one and a half years and he lives with
me
here's the juicy part he has a best
friend since middle school let's call
him joe
and all of us went to college together
joe and i have always gotten along
really well have similar personalities
interests etc and multiple people have
made comments about our chemistry over
the years
recently we went on a group camping trip
sounds like torture
and joe made a few comments about how he
needs to find a girl like me how i'm
marrying the wrong guy etc
i grew up on a cattle farm and i've
always pictured myself staying being a
stay-at-home mom
but my boyfriend told me i'll be
expected to work when having kids
it's a little [ __ ] rude
joe manages a cat because it's like it
sounds it doesn't sound bad until you
really think about it so it's like a
little
[ __ ] rude you know what i mean
joe manages a cattle ranch and says
he can financially support a wife to
stay home help i love my boyfriend and
don't even know how this logistically
could ever work but we're talking about
a lifelong marriage here and if our
family slash long-term goals
don't align i don't want to be divorced
with two kids in five years when joe has
a ranch and seemingly ideal
solution waiting thank you my beautiful
stunning and smart queens
okay first of all i feel like
there's two things going on here like
you might be unhappy in your
relationship
and then you might have feelings for
this other guy but like i feel like you
like the guy's ranch
more than you like him you know okay
also i want to be you i want these to be
my choices like a cattle ranch you know
i i feel a lot of ways about this first
of all like i ship you and joe i really
do
but the reasons why you would choose him
over your existing boyfriend
have to be more than like he has a
cattle ranch because you wouldn't have
to work
right and i understand like maybe there
is a connection and everyone sees it and
everyone gets it but there is a very big
difference between
you know flirting with someone when you
see them and it's like a fun exciting
like totally off-limits thing versus
being in a relationship with someone and
obviously you're like sick and tired of
your boyfriend of
six years yeah and he's old news and joe
and his cattle ranch are looking really
good right now
yeah i very much endorse you um
breaking up with your boyfriend and
going to joe
but it has to be for the real deep and
right reason and more than just the
rants and more than just the ranch but i
also will say that if you guys are
dating and you already don't see your
future
the same way or in a similar light like
those things don't change
right and not saying that joe is the
answer
but this is still a problem right so i
think
the the thing you have to do is take a
look at your own relationship if you
guys are you have to take joe out of the
equation right you guys are clearly on
two different
you know planets on in terms of what you
want for your life like you want to be a
stay-at-home mom which is a totally
valid lifestyle and he doesn't want that
so is that a deal-breaker for you that's
something you need to think about
yeah but take make this decision
absent of job or pretend that joe is
married and
happily off limits like just
joe died for a minute okay yeah what is
your decision
in regards to the boyfriend you need to
make one decision at a time
jackie boyfriend what's that from come
on friends no
think about it you've seen it's a movie
okay and what about le boyfriend
oh sounds familiar billy bush
billy bush the billy bush look-alike in
devil wears prada
yeah i would have absolutely never
gotten that next up
oh really because every time he says it
it's so cringy it sends a chill down my
spine
boyfriend just say where's your
boyfriend like we're not in france we're
in new york
um hi jackie and claudia sorry hi
claudia and
jackie okay putting some respect on my
name
i am a true loyal supporter and fan of
your show and i look forward to your
beautiful stunning and smart selves
racing my screen every day thank you
just you know just what to say
i am desperate for some advice from two
happily married gals like
she wrote myself but i think she means
yourselves
i truly am at a loss with some of my
husband's most recent behaviors
since being in the queue together in our
apartment i have noticed an increase in
my husband
i've noticed an increase in my husband
picking his nose
picking his earwax biting his finger and
toenails yes that does takes lots a lot
of flexibility
i will often suggest getting him the
proper tools to to sanitarily do such
things such as q-tip
tissue nail clipper i even so much
adopted spa
sunday in the queue so that we can soak
him trim and clean up our nails and do
other necessary tweezing and
maintaining these areas together with
the proper tools
his barber even waxes his nose and ears
when he goes and gets his hair cut
most recently i've caught him no
i can't read it i can't tell you you're
gonna die
you you cannot read it okay
most recently i don't
just what did he do recently i have
caught him
i have caught him tasting his boogers
[ __ ] cat
smelling and tasting his earwax and
chewing on his toenails
i am skeeved out to no end i can't
believe i catch him doing such a
repulsive disgusting childish not to
mention unsanitary thing
mind you my husband is a polished
professional well-respected attorney
and i'm just appalled that he becomes
this animal when he's very long
i'm appalled when he becomes this animal
when he is at home and i know
anyone else would too i call him out all
the time and refuse to touch kiss or
give him any affection
i will go so far to remind him when we
have children and they see you doing
that they will think it's accessible
acceptable
and in no time our children are going to
be the class booger eaters
what else can i do to stop him this is
absolutely disgusting and i don't want
him to continue doing this ever
but i don't want to continue nagging and
constantly calling him out over and over
again thank you so so much with love
escaped out
spouse wow okay
um this is problematic i thought we had
a handle on it until you said
tasting his ear wax oh really you
thought it was fine when he was eating
his boogers you know what like somehow
eating boogers has been normalized
like that's what kids do that's what
kids do
what are you talking about it's not
normal it's true but this isn't the
first time i've heard of someone eating
their boogers
i this is the first time you've never
heard of somebody seeing their boogers
over the age of ten oh no
no but like i've never even heard of a
nine-year-old teething their ears
yeah that's [ __ ] disgusting so uh
we've crossed a line here
like it was already bad but we're in
unchartered territory
because i don't even know how you get
enough ear wax on your finger
to taste it maybe put it on accumulated
like a lollipop
i can't [ __ ] breathe honestly okay
there's only one choice here
divorce yeah sorry this
is so so crazy and i'm sorry biting his
toenails like is he
at a gymnast well he should quit being
an attorney enjoy the circus
he's very talented
i don't know what to tell you i'm out of
my depth yeah no this is beyond like
this is just another level
you have to leave you need to like find
a medication that would dry up his ear
[Music]
wow
what would you do no i don't know
ben does some weird things he's going to
kill me but like
you know i can't even say he does some
weird things but like i've learned to
love it and he just has to watch it
and like men are are more disgusting
their hands are always in their balls
but there's a level that we can live
with and this is beyond that level and i
wonder what's
like if you've had a conversation with
him but i mean these are really really
bad habits they can be
broken because you know some people bite
their nails and then they learn to stop
i mean i just know these girls bite
their toenails and then they learn
this girl is two weeks away from like
finding a booger wall behind their bed
or like a collection of clippings from
his toenails this is just the tip of the
iceberg yeah right no
like where is he putting all this
excrement sometimes he's eating it but
sometimes he's flicking it somewhere
yeah divorce that is my
final answer here's what i don't get
though sometimes you can't
help up bite your nails because it's
like a reflex and you don't even realize
you're doing it but the effort that it
takes to bite your toenails
it's a choice it's a choice when you can
pick your nails while watching tv
or even in a zoom meeting but like if
your
foot is in your mouth and you can't be
doing anything else he literally has his
foot in his mouth you know what i would
never trust this guy as my attorney like
literally he's a danger to society he
should be arrested
yeah no this is sick i'm so sorry you
sound fabulous
and i'm so sorry that you have to be
single now
yeah yeah it's terrible oh man i was
just not expecting to hear that you know
yeah okay final one hey jackie and
claudia longtime toaster here who was so
nervous about writing in i haven't told
anyone this that i think i just need to
let it out
i'm one of four children it's me and my
twin brother who i am very close with
our older sister who was five years
older and another sister who was younger
than us
because of quarantine my brother and i
are home from college and my older
sister came home from across the country
and brought her longtime boyfriend to
quarantine with us let's call him pinky
right around the beginning of quarantine
i went in to sneak into my brother's
bedroom at 2 a.m to get a hoodie
wait okay can you back up two sentences
yeah because i'm about to be shook and i
need
i need to paint the picture okay so this
girl and her twin brother they're home
from college
from college and older sister and her
boyfriend are home from college
boyfriend's name is pinky got it okay
so she went into her twin brother's
bedroom at 2 a.m to get a hoodie okay
when i opened his door his being her
brother i saw him and pinky having sex
so her twin brother and her sister's
boyfriend having sex
i was in complete shock i quietly closed
the door and did not sleep the rest of
the night i had absolutely no idea my
brother was interested in men at all
which is surprising because we are so
close
and as close as siblings could be the
next night i stayed up to see if pinkie
snuck into my brother's room and he did
so the next day i confronted my brother
about it he broke down crying he says
they are in love
i have absolutely no idea what to tell
him apparently this isn't his first male
relationship either
and he was too afraid to tell any of us
my parents are very mormon and would
most likely not support him if they knew
he also said pinkie is planning on
breaking it off with my sister but it's
been four months and pinky and my sister
are still together and my mother told me
pinky asked her and my father for
permission to propose
i didn't tell my brother that for fear
of hurting him next week my sister and
pinky are leaving to go back to their
home
i need your help i don't want to out
anyone if i tell my sister what's been
going on then she'll tell everyone
because that's who she is do i let my
sister marry a cheater or do i ruin
my brother or do i do nothing sincerely
a toaster who just wants to be a good
sister
wow there are so many elements here i
mean so many
i understand why she hasn't told anyone
and how she doesn't know how to navigate
it because there are so many different
things happening
yeah i feel like my instinct would be to
protect my twin brother who's obviously
in a very vulnerable state
being in the closet and in a very
religious family that probably wouldn't
she said except him so like whatever
steps i took would be ultimately to
protect my twin brother i think
like your sister will get her heart
broken but like that's pales in
comparison to what pinkie could go
through
you can't let your sister marry him of
course not so i think you talked to your
brother about talking
to the sister about it them together and
if he
if you if you can get him to do that
then that would be great if you can't i
think that you have to tell your sister
that pinky is cheating on her but not
say with who
right and hopefully you guys have a good
relationship and she trusts you
like if you came to me and said that
my partner was cheating on me you cannot
tell me like how you know
or who it is but just but i would
believe like you have to just believe me
but that i would just have to believe
you like i would believe you yes of
course
also there's the route of this sister
going straight to pinky and being being
like i know i refuse to let you marry my
sister i'll blow this whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
if you don't break up with her yeah or
tell her yeah but then you run the risk
of outing the brother
right which we need to protect the
brother at all costs at all costs and i
don't know what the
what the long term like what's the goal
for the brother like to keep his
sexuality hidden from their parents
forever
yeah or and also there's the element
that he is in love with pinky
but i just don't trust this pinky no
i mean but pinky could be in a similar
situation as the brother
where it's like they're in this mormon
community and they're
both gay and he's just doing what he's
been told to do but just find a nice
mormon girl to get married
but he can't deny who he is yeah i
almost feel bad for pinkie too
yeah it's not so much that he's a
cheater it's that he's living a lie
yeah and he doesn't know and maybe like
maybe he's gonna propose to the sister
and
just because he thinks that this is what
he's supposed to be doing
i mean the twin sister the toaster who
found this out like men did she step in
some [ __ ] like this is just
no no easy way out of this someone's
going to get hurt
and i think that her priority should be
whatever decision you decide to make
must prioritize the safety and
protection of your brother
i agree so i would start with going
seeing if the brother will come to you
and talk to your sister if you won't
talk to your sister alone give her a
limited information but like
also whatever you do run it by your
brother yes of course he
needs to be looped in every step of the
way and then maybe
if the circumstances allow for it
there's a
meeting between the sister pinky the
brother
and the other sister everyone who knows
the cards are on the table they talk
about the situation and they deal with
it
but also with the sensitivity of not
sharing it with the parents because then
you also run the risk of
the older sister whose boyfriend cheated
on her with her brother like that is a
betrayal
of her being so angry at the brother and
then like in in retaliation telling the
parents that the twin brother is gay
because she's mad at him yeah she's
going to be hurt too right
hurt people hurt people yeah i'm really
this is a really tough spot to be in
i know but now i understand the
inclination to not do anything because
it's just too complicated
but you have to and i think that no
matter what happens what the fallout is
if it all blows up
you need to be a good sister to your
brother like that
i can't stress enough like i can't even
imagine how traumatizing it is to be
gay hiding it and with no plan of coming
out like
and i just think if it all blows up in
his face and the family doesn't accept
him like you just have to be a good
sister like that is the priority
yeah i agree terrible
but good batch of dear toasters today
yes very good batch
justice for the second girl i will be
thinking about her for the rest of the
day
yeah please feel free to share updates
on your decisions
and i hope joe and the girl even though
it's not about joe
no but i do ship i would love to see you
in a few years on that ranch girlfriends
yeah make it happen
yeah but only after you know taking time
for yourself
going through a breakup not just jumping
into decisions because you like the way
that they look
and their farm and farm um quickly
before we wrap up i just want to talk
about the shaws of sunset reunion
which was probably the most contentious
reunion i've seen in my time and
andy went on radio andy and said it was
like the most vicious place you'd ever
been like
they were saying the absolute nastiest
things to each other most of which they
had to cut out like it was just
so the show it was almost bad how
how mean the reunion was because there's
no coming back from it
and i feel so torn because forever reza
and mj were both of my favorite people
and i
i think i'm on mj's side like for the
most part partially just because i love
her and she comes on the show so much
and
i can't imagine her being mean because
she's lovely
and partially because most of what reza
is claiming to be upset about her
there's no proof
and it all happened off camera so it's
like what reza did to mj
is all on camera saying that horrible
thing about abortions on camera on
camera
so it's like we're supposed to disagree
with mj when i don't i was so confused
at the end i don't even know what we're
fighting about anymore like yeah and
they asked everyone to leave except for
reza mj and then had mike and andy
mediate which i thought was a great
format but they were just not even
listening to each other
screaming getting up every 10 seconds
leaving coming back leaving coming back
it was it was like devastating like
these two people are
net like they're never going to be
friends again so you did your poll on
instagram
oh let me see what the results were it
was not a landslide but mj was winning
slightly now it is ready
sixty percent mj 40
reza yeah which
is not even like a real landslide
no but i guess that's i feel like that
reflects how you feel about it yeah and
i still love reza but like honestly
adam is just the worst and he's the
cause of all of this and he did admit
that
and andy was like can you admit that
like if you didn't send these text
messages like none of this would have
happened and he was like yeah i can and
like the whole cast started clapping
because it was like this friendship of
30 years has been deteriorated from your
poor decisions and it's like
i don't even blame reza so much because
he's just doing what he's going to do to
protect his family because him and adam
are still married
and even though is that the person i
would have chose for reza no
but it is who he chose and that's that
on that like he's just defending his
husband and part of me like respects him
for that
but what he said to mj towards the end
of the season was just so unbelievably
not okay yeah it was just it was like
not even a
i didn't get any closure from the
reunion it was just
and everyone like piling on mj like
destiny and gigi like i wasn't here for
that at all
no like gigi just hates mj like 100
like she's hated her forever and destiny
just wants to be on the show i think and
she just wants to do what the group is
doing so she doesn't become an outcast
like mj is now
i haven't watched your union you're not
making me want to it wasn't fabulous i'm
not gonna lie yeah
that and it's just like where do you go
from there when like
right so i'm gonna still leave the show
yeah
so it'll be interesting the show suffers
yeah no mj has been
made the show so great for so long was
the real familial connection and
30 years of friendship most people just
the real house is in new york they never
see each other they just get together to
film like this was a real group of
friends
and the show ruined it yeah i mean
that's what shows do
that's what shows do um anything else we
want to discuss before we wrap it up
no i think that's all she wrote if you
are rdh that this episode is ending head
to patreon.com
the morning toast and check out all the
premium content we have there including
our latest episode our sias to the dress
viewing party
thank you oh i came up with the new oh
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast on
youtube every day monday through friday
and we're also available as a podcast
and where podcasts can be found so
that's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i already cast box all the places
where we listened to the podcast five
nights at mornington's level five star
viewer
beautiful stunning and smart we are i'm
still working on it you know i like that
i like where it's headed wrapping it up
again like do you want to add the crunch
to it like no
no no no no no the crunch is special
like for special moments online okay
okay um
and that's all she wrote thank you guys
have a great day we'll see you tomorrow
for our final show
of the week we will not be doing a show
on friday we are taking a small little
getaway a little staycation
um so we will well we're actually like
leaving the city so it's not a vacation
but you know i'm just
we're in new york we're still um so yeah
no show friday but we
will have a video and podcast episode
for you tomorrow thursday for the final
episode of the week
yes can't wait goodbye
you